in 2017 fans of creepy clown high jinks
rushed to the theater breaking
box-office records in a rush to see the
remake of hit adapted from the Stephen
King book of the same name the film was
met with wide acclaim and hailed as a
new classic but just because something
is awesome doesn't mean it can't be kind
of stupid - despite its iconic scenes
killer writing and knockout performances
it has its share of moments that left us
scratching our heads georgie who if you
know anyone who lost a sibling growing
up you're probably very aware that it's
a devastating blow that can tear apart
both families and communities accepting
dairy in dairy you mostly shrug it off
and make fun of your friend's mom when
Georgie goes missing the only people who
seem torn up about it are bill and his
dad probably his mom - her entire
contribution seems to be providing
incidental piano music for her youngest
child to get eaten by a clown - everyone
deals with tragedy in their own way but
none of the kids seem to do much to
process the fact that a little boy
straight up disappeared into the great
unknown
detective Bend that Benjamin is a heck
of a dude he's got an eye for detail and
an inquisitive mind would you believe he
was the first person in all of Gary's
history to notice that there's an
inexplicable disaster every 27 years how
is it that in a town that's been around
for presumably about 260 years the first
person to notice this trend is a bored
kid on summer break none of the cops or
teachers or historians in this town has
ever been thumbing through a history of
dairy and noticed the kids get killed
here on an alarmingly regular basis
congratulations kid you're this
universe's Batman
librarian hubris we find Ben in the
library studying up on possible past it
encounters he's learning that's good we
want him in the library there's only one
person who doesn't want him in the
library and that's the librarian isn't
it summer vacation I would think you'd
be ready to take a break from the books
she kicks a quietly studious child out
of the library
you know like librarians do was there
really a point in history when
librarians were so securing the idea
that libraries would be around forever
that they'd shoe inquisitive patrons out
the door if she's still working today
she probably looks back longingly on the
days when you could have picked someone
from the library for something besides
trying to live in the bathroom
history class take a look at Ben's
bedroom it's got pictures and newspaper
clippings lining the walls and well this
how he got all of this information home
when he apparently can't leave the
library without getting mugged as a
mystery in itself but that isn't the
point who shows up in an illustration
you'd better believe it's Pennywise in a
print of the signing of dairy's town
charter but it's showing up in an old
image means one of two things either it
is doing his usual routine of projecting
into places he shouldn't be or else it
was there at Town Hall in the late 1700s
and not only did nobody mention or
object to it but he just barely
warranted making it into the 18th
century equivalent of the group photo
how could you forget that face who
taught you murder as far as we know it
has one job eaten kids that's its whole
deal it's been popping up every 27 years
to do just that so why is he so bad at
it how many kids does he kill two maybe
four depending on how you count the
children of Derry would have been in
more danger if a bad flu had hit the
town and what about the bullies that it
eliminated in a way it saved more lives
than he took by nipping those pieces of
work in the bud pick Elaine Pennywise
there's the argument that it feeds on
children's fear to counterpoints first
in a much more literal sense he feeds on
children secondly in the book it refers
to causing fear is more of a way of
salting the meat which means this dude
is risking his life to season his steak
pretty fancy for a guy who spends his
time in the sewers speaking of diseases
of Derry let's discuss for a moment what
makes sewers so important they convey
human waste rain water runoff and our
ill-fated goldfish from cities two
treatment plants and disposal outlets
they're more or less the key thing that
separates us from apes but they're rife
with disease and these kids are
traipsing through them like there are
McDonald's play place sorry every one of
these kids is getting hepatitis Eddy
brings us up when they first start
exploring the Barrens but you know what
sassiness doesn't protect you from
cholera
maybe we're projecting the losers Club
heads to Bill's garage where bill has
set up what's doomed to be the second
worst TED talk about clowns of all time
they're flipping through slides when the
slide projector takes on a life of its
own until a series of photos of Bill and
Georgie's mom undergoes a nightmarish
transformation mom straight up turns
into Pennywise and then nobody unplugs
the projector
mic kicks the projector off the table
but still nobody turns it off everybody
in the room just screams and wigs out
failing to take their lives or in fact
the power cord into their own hands
bin's got guts
tough guy bin walks off an astonishing
number of gut injuries in this movie
first the bullies tried to carve their
names into him with a switchblade which
he escapes by tumbling down a dirt Hill
and trouncing through sewer runoff only
to have his wounds treated by children
with drugstore bandages then in the
creepy house bin gets slashed in the
belly by if which he just sort of seems
to ignore afterward after that first
Haunted Mansion encounter he's just
standing out in the street with
four-foot long gashes in his abdomen you
could maybe see his appendix if you
squint it's worth pointing out that
during that whole scene Eddie's mom is
standing in front of been watching him
bleed from his torso and she thinks it's
more important to shame a
twelve-year-old than it is to find him a
doctor the adults in this town are a
mess define death in a lot of ways it
isn't supposed to make sense it's a
piece of horror fiction that deals in
the supernatural but still there's one
thing that really truly doesn't make any
sense
specifically how are those insanely
self-destructive bullies still alive all
we see them do in this movie is take
needless risks for two hours they drive
blindly down alleyways at breakneck
speed
they make flame throwers out of cans of
hairspray they dive headfirst down steep
hills covered in debris they play with
loaded guns they're the definition of
awful it shouldn't have taken an extra
dimensional demon to beat these jerks
with their behavior every one of them
should have been a full color in loving
memory page in the yearbook by their
sophomore year
[Music]